- action.
- hey, have you ever
found yourself
in high point, north carolina,
and not feeling safe?
come on down to doug duggart's
brazilian jiu jitsu.
you will learn
to tackle and grapple,
[gong rings]
and--
[gong echoing]
like a ultimate fighting pro.
at my studio, you get
hands-on training,
[both grunting]
and individual attention.
so hut! hut!
[grunting]
tackle and grapple.
take on multiple enemies.
this is a tackle.
that's a grapple.
get--there we go.
[grunts]
tackle and grapple!
all ages, learn to protect
yourself and your loved ones.
there are many
different levels.
there's the beginner level,
and if you pass my private
one-on-one sensei trial,
you may make it
into the advanced class.
tackle and grapple!
doug duggart's
brazilian jiu jitsu
at the high point mini mall.
just east of the pizza barn
two doors down from carl's
discount wheels and furniture.
so--quick tackle!
get down. [grunts]
[muttering]
[all grunting]
no, stay--stay away.
special discounts
for college students.
s--mm, move it.
get your leg back.
[gong rings]
put your leg back there.
[gong echoing]